Hey, Vsauce. Michael here. And today
we're going to get close, like really close.
In fact, I want to answer the question
what's the closest we can get to other objects
and other people?
Now, it might sound like kind of a simple easy question,
but when we get down to the atoms of it,
it's quite complex and might leave
you feeling a little bit alone.
When I go like this, my fingers, for all
intents and purposes, are touching.
But, at an atomic level, they're not.
That's right, in fact, if you're sitting in a chair
right now, your body is technically not touching the chair
at all. Instead, you are hovering above the chair
by some tiny, tiny atomically sized gap,
something too small for us to even see, but it's there.
And it's caused by the fact that your butt and the chair are made out of atoms.
Now, as we all know, the matter that we deal with every day is made out of atoms.
And an atom is a nucleus surrounded by an outer shell
of orbiting electrons.
Now when two atoms get close to each other
that aren't going to bond or chemically react,
they have trouble touching each other.
Why? Because electrons repel one another,
because they have the same charge.
And because of a fancy thing
called the Pauli exclusion principle,
we also know that all of an atoms electrons
cannot all be pushed down to the same energy level
all together on the same shell.
So what this means is that if I touch something,
I'm technically not really touching it.
The atoms are getting quite close together,
but the electromagnetic repulsion between electrons
is saying no, no, no, no, closer.
Now, of course, the nerves in my skin can feel that repulsive force and that's what I call
the texture or the feeling of the object.
If I push hard enough of course, I can break or poke into
or cut something, but I'm not touching
any of its matter, I'm just pushing it out of the way
using the electron-electron repulsion forces.
Even though you can cut things really easily like this,
the scissors never touched the card.
This is where it gets depressing.
What all of this means is that when you kissed
your girlfriend or pet your dog
or hug your grandmother, you're not actually
making contact with their matter.
You're not technically touching them, you're just feeling
the repulsive force of their electrons.
But maybe there's hope.
Let's just avoid electrons altogether and ask ourselves
what can we do to affect the nucleus of
someone else's atoms?
Maybe we can do that?
You're going to have to be a little bit
radioactive if you're going to want to do this
and luckily, people are a little bit radioactive.
In fact, if you sleep in a bed with another person
for an entire year,
your body is actually exposed to one millirem
more radiation than someone who sleeps alone.
Now, we are talking about tiny, tiny amounts that really don't affect your body at all,
but still, they are there.
How did they get there?
Well, carbon 14 is in the air, and potassium 40
is in bananas, that's right.
Bananas have a really high potassium content.
In fact, any food that has a lot of potassium in it, like Brazil nuts, is going to act the same way.
All of that potassium is fine and dandy,
but about one out of every 8,000 or so potassium atoms
is a radioactive isotope of potassium.
In fact, if you were to eat 600 bananas,
it would be the equivalent of getting a chest x-ray.
Okay, cool, so I am a little bit radioactive.
Does that mean that if I hug someone really close that some sort of radioactive ray
might come out of my body and go into someone else's body and get absorbed into
a nucleus of one of their atoms and then we could really finally say that we touched on a fundamental level?
Maybe.
The radiation that comes out of us is very unlikely to hit someone else's atoms and
because people don't contain
a lot of radioactive material
in the bodies, that energy is just going to get absorbed and you're not going to really know that it happens
and the chance, like I said, is super unlikely.
So maybe we should go back
a little bit and talk about chemical reactions.
Back when I mentioned
that atoms have trouble touching,
they are a little more friendly if they
get together and, you know, share electrons.
Now, this kind of stuff is happening all the time.
When I eat food, my body is chemically reacting with that food to take out the nutrients,
get rid of the stuff I don't want, but
short of being a cannibal
and eating someone's arm or being a zombie,
how can I get chemically,
reactionally close to a person?
Well, luckily, there is a thing called birth.
When you're growing inside your mother,
your father and mother's DNA
are all working together
in chemical ways to create you.
Because they're sharing electrons
it seems at least more like a touch.
I guess what I'm trying to say is that, in a way,
your parents and your children
are the only people you can know for
certain you've come the closest
to actually touching.
And that's touching.
And as always,
thanks for watching.